what end off what are we doing here
that's deep bro hi welcome to that's
deep bro serious questions with silly
people i'm christina pazsitzky and see
if we can turn the volume down I
appreciate it but it's Kate hi welcome
sorry I'm a little a little slow and
discombobulated today I don't know why I
think I've been traveling too much and
that I need to you know I'm gonna do
after this episode is over I'm gonna go
to the beach how about that and today
we're talking about a Zen and surfing
what is that why why do people say that
surfing bro is the solution tell your
your worldly problems I feel like you
know I grew up in LA and I grew up
watching reruns of Gidget you know you
watch all these silly surfer movies and
you're like what why why why are people
so drawn to this so my guest today is
Graham Elwood and we're going to get
into it Zen and the spirituality of
surfing before that though please come
see me do stand-up guys come on you know
I mean look I'm coming to Indianapolis
februari 19th through 21st so come see
me do stand-up at Morty's comedy joint
and then one night only I'm going to be
at Louisville although Kentucky februari
22nd at the Derby the Laughing Derby
it's a new new venue my friends are
running it I think it's going to be
really fun my husband did it a month ago
and he loved it and also washington DC
district of columbia mark
5th through six did I say that no March
5th through 8th God listen to me what
what is going to happen on today's
episode March 5th through 8th come see
me do stand-up in Washington DC oh my
album man of the year is on sale on
iTunes if you don't like iTunes please
download it at cdbaby and if you would
like i'm the first 100 physical copies
i'm selling autographed on my website
that's the rope podcast calm as well as
your mom's house podcast com yeah do
your shopping on Amazon through my
banner at your chase dear shopping on
Amazon through my banner that's deep bro
podcast calm if you don't know I'm
talking about like next time you do your
shopping on Amazon go to that's deep bro
podcast calm and click on my banner and
like it just kicks back some shekels to
my show helps me out makes things happy
Twitter I Christina p Instagram on
Instagram are you want Instagram I like
that one so much more I like Instagram I
like seeing people's lives but I follow
a lot more dogs on Instagram than I do
people what does that say about me who
knows well okay here we go I'm
spirituality and surfing and you don't
necessarily have to be a surfer I think
to appreciate the conversation we will
have um we'll see grandma when's the
super funny guy I've known him for a
million zillion years and yeah let's get
into it man
time so here's grandma would Graham I've
met you million years ago I would say
you were the first headliner I think I
ever spoke to what's up the way of the
picture that you're painting with that
dismiss like how did that how did that
interaction happen wise you're the first
like like ice like we used to do this
dump call martini blues and if you're
mad right the bill word shows yes that's
where we met I knew it that's awesome
yes yes yes yes so for those of you
don't would like so far from LA who who
else was always on it um Bernadette
Bernadette balik test my luck pass was
always on her Natalie grey yeah yes so
yeah yeah and uh I was like the token
white guy it was all like women and
minority women it was like Nadine Rajabi
was always with ya love Nadine it was
all the best IRA god I miss those shows
those billboard shows were so fun yeah
they were cuz they there were an hour
south of Los Angeles so you really had
to commit to doing you know your eight
minutes at martini blue yeah and thank
God for it cuz nobody should have seen
me do stand-up in LA for the first seven
years I was doin comedy but you are the
first headliner that I was like whoa
first of all here's two things I
remember distinctly it was a hard night
at martini Blues one night it was it was
just one of those nights where everybody
was eating dicks and you got up there
and you said the funniest [__] you go
all right you guys aren't having fun
looks lock these doors we're gonna read
the Bible or something like that I was
like wow who says that to people is
amazing what a great job and I love that
you were gonna force them to read we're
gonna read the Bible so silly do you
still say that lines of once in a blue
moon if it's like a really stiff crowd
yeah or they're talking or being like
I'll throw that in there that came from
I was born you know I'm from the Midwest
and so my stand-up actually i started my
stand-up career as a freshman in college
at the University of Arizona so smart
but
yeah was 18 ah and it was just you know
but then I moved back to Chicago where
I'm from and just made my living
grinding it out in every holiday in
lounge bowling alley and just so like
martini blues was like ah this is a cake
this is this an orange county like how
that you know there's no but there's no
bikers that want to beat me up there's
just like people who are mad their lexus
didn't get detailed that day or whatever
right so I mean I would I I mean I used
to literally that's how I made my living
was doing one nighters like that for a
hundred bucks a show Wow 150 bucks now I
did not know this and then living in
Chicago and this is in the early 90s
there was 12 full-time comedy clubs in
the Chicago area and then within a six
hour radius you could fill your calendar
and you would do these light was through
like John Yoder so you would do these
like you know tuesday in la crosse
wisconsin wednesday in dubuque and then
you know thursday friday saturday you
close in Madison that was like that you
get the right they tack and what they
were had a bowling alley run oh my god
every night was a different lounge in a
bowling alley in southern Illinois and
it was like four hours driving between
this is not this is yoder and not
Tribble is is Yoda to the sound guy
basically yeah there's another guy named
David Tribble who books he'll runs yeah
yeah every every region of the country
has a he'll run person and the Midwest
Wisconsin Minnesota uh mainly Wisconsin
Michigan and Illinois and Indiana was
was John Yoder okay so yeah and God and
you so you just you just when you got to
a nice weekend room it was like it was
cake because you had just been fighting
it out with these goddamn animals you
know and every once in a while you'd get
one that was like oh this was run okay
this wasn't i bet i'll talk i could tell
stories like this for hours but i
remember i did one of these things at a
sports bar and it was a two-man show and
I was the first guy was the emcee so I
was doing like 30 and then the headline
MC and the feature is what yeah okay yes
usually they hire two people to do one
person
yeah this job in your butt you got okay
just so the audience normally there's an
MC that does 10 to 15 a feature that
does 30 in a closer that does 45 or so
so this is a two-man show so I'm doing
30 and then the headliner is going to do
an hour yeah yeah in a sports bar sure
and it is a final it is you know March
Madness it's tournament basketball
season which people love to pay
attention to comics it's what they want
right they don't wear in the sports yeah
whether whether it's going insane with
face paint they're definitely they're
definitely gonna face paint your next
album right right oh this is and um you
know the owner manager comes up and goes
you know we'll wait till the game's over
and then we'll turn all the TV's off
work thank God thank God how many TVs
are we talking all ten and a giant one
hanging above the stage always oh we
gotta have that right behind you or
above yeah above you yep so the and it
was someone was playing it was like
Illinois vs michigan so we are in
Illinois was all these Illinois fans
game goes into overtime manager it goes
well we got to start the show ladies and
gentlemen comedy with grandma would
while there's a game playing above my
head I'm not exaggerating in the
slightest and I was just going no one's
looking at me they're all gone all well
that's a foul you know so I just started
announcing the game I was like jazz for
the ball coming up the fireside wow he's
got flat feet nice haircut you know what
I'm just and I was getting some laughs
with that but then Michigan beats
Illinois so this table fillin oi
die-hard Illinois people are then pissed
I'm going into my act now because at
least at this point you have retracted
the screen about you know 12 minutes
into my Center which isn't distracting
at all that's how you want to do I deal
I asked for it everyone in my shows yeah
you should actually have any noise going
on now during this pile of that is there
some sports we can play under year I
love oh so much the blisters could have
seen you look to your board like is
there a
a screen retractable noise i can hit
button doesn't this sound bored come
with that so they then start yelling you
know they're heckling mean they're mad
so then I started to sing the Michigan
fight song and then I got half the crowd
to laugh and then I brought the headline
or whatever so that that's where I cut
my teeth so that's why martini blues was
like cake walk Anjelah Johnson used to
do those shows too she won the funniest
female there was a California's funniest
female contest and yes she won one year
and I I think I won second place I lost
two wreaths a Jones one year who's
really funny but yeah so that's why I
met you and and here's the thing I was I
remember so distinctly about you is that
you were the first comic I met that
actually had a hobby because i think
that people don't do that anymore
there's a sense of well if I can't make
a million dollars with this thing why am
I going to do this and you had the hobby
of surfing and I thought that is the
coolest thing ever that you actually do
something because most of us stand-ups
you know we live in dark caves and we're
nocturnal and none of us see the
sunlight so how did that come about how
did you get into surfing um I got into
surfing um well I've always wanted to do
it I grew up like I said I grew up in
the Midwest and then moved to Southern
Luke moved to LA and I was living in the
valley at the time I grew up there yeah
i saw i was living in the valley and it
was one of those things i always like
you know you grew up in the Midwest
Southern California is this like magic
land in your eyes you're just like no
way their servers and it's always sunny
and you know all the show business comes
out of here so surfing was one of these
things and I think I had into my mind
like part of me was like I could never
you know you got to grow up doing it or
forget it I don't know I had a dumb idea
about it yeah cuz it's a it's hard it's
it is really hard and so I just figured
well you gotta grow you know you got to
be seven years old on a board or its
you're sure yeah so I had moved from the
valley to the beach in whatever it was
and and I was like wow you know I had a
boogie board mm-hmm and I was doing her
shal for direct TV and the camera guys
were shooting and we're shooting in my
house is like a fake testimonial like
Grandma or direct TV subscriber you know
the producer is a buddy of mine those
aren't real yeah yeah i know its own
everything's a lie um and I was and one
of the camera guys they're setting up
there like she lives this close to the
beach because I could walk and they're
like do you serve no I'm really figured
I'm I keep thinking maybe I should take
a lesson but you know I boogie board the
camera guy goes nobody ever picked up a
chick with a boogie board in his arm and
I was like okay that's that and I'm
sorry yeah like a total yeah he may as
well just called you a [__] you don't
want to do any idiot kicked me in the
dick is what he did and he enhanced me
you did it basically he verbally pants
but boogie-boarding I grew up doing that
here in LA and there's nothing more fun
and buggy boring it's super fun it's an
instant fun you have there's very little
skill you just get on it let the end you
splash around it's a blast yeah it is a
blast it's not sexy that it's not sexy
at all it's like oh there's the tourists
yeah like yes well the Canadians are
here wow you before you guys for Iowa or
the twin cities are the twins I love it
I can always tell who's a tour is just
and I God love them I get it they're
always super pasty compared to the rest
of us um and they're always wearing the
wrong [__] at the beach like they're
always wearing jeans and moccasins like
full jeans you know you can't do that
bro we don't do that so if you're
tourists don't do that they have a
boogie board you're mocking yeah oh poor
look guys so okay so the guys like
you're totally lame and how old are you
at this point you know I don't know I'm
in late 20s early 30s oh cool yeah so
then I wasn't thinking about okay I want
to do it and then ice did a couple of
these comedy tours to Afghanistan yes
and I did the second one um with shame
atosh hey remember Shaima yeah and it
was a pretty it was it was an intense
experience with those shows over there
are amazing
yeah but it was a it was a hard like we
were on a helicopter they came under
fire and April 27 2006 and we released
countermeasures which is if you're on a
helicopter and you get targeted by a
rocket they release flares so the rocket
chases the flares wow I didn't want to
put these on because I'm used to it I
can't talk to you about do it that's so
that so did you just s your pants or how
does one react it was my second time
being over there and you know the
helicopters shooting like a 60 caliber
machine guns like I got in like spent
shells are bouncing off my face and a
35-minute uh supposed to be a 30-40
minute helicopter ride from jallalabad
to Bagram ended up being an hour and a
half we to stop and refuel and pick up
some real sketchy CIA dudes with no
insignias and some local guy who was
handcuffed like it was like and we were
in a firefight like shooting and then we
get off that and shame and I were just
like holy [__] and then the next day
they take us into a hospital and they're
like kids at local Afghani kids have
been playing in a minefield and they're
operating on them and they're showing us
all this and then the flight home well
from Bagram to Kyrgyzstan it was the end
of the tour about two weeks or were then
on a c-130 with two coffins yeah and we
were just like wow like it's a war zone
no joke this is not CNN your lip you're
right there you know and I came back and
was just like a little out of it yeah
and just like I don't know if I can go
back because at that time I just I've
been hosting game shows and and I was
just like really show business yeah it
was weird i was very torn cuz part of me
felt like well i'm an idiot show
business is stupid but then you do these
shows in these little basis in front of
35 Marines yes it means the world yeah
you've done them yeah afghanistan and
specifically kyrgyzstan and then
afghanistan we did we couldn't go to
Bagram by the time I got there in twenty
two thousand nine or ten
not allowed to go there anymore um it
affected me to like I came back and I
was like shell-shocked the old-school
word for ugh you that's PTSD yeah you
see [__] and we're just tourists and I'm
like I went as a tourist imagine really
being there and I came back and I have a
therapist thankfully I go to every week
and I just bawled I cried for weeks man
because you kids burned up and you're
just like what yes because they sure
this is what you did you get there then
you you know they let's go to the
medical tent and you get the wounded
soldiers yes which is an honor to do but
that is not easy no and I've done seven
of those now so now when I go I'm like
we're going in the medical tent boys
like big smiley faces good to see you
hey kid where you're from but then I
always got to get out of there and just
go cry because you're just like oh
there's a 25 year old without an arm
yeah k a five year old guy kids 19 20
yeah and you see that stuff and it's
like it's funny every comic I've ever
known that's gone over there has that
experience and we all sort of feel
similar like well if I'm freaking out on
a two-week comedy tours what is a
12-month combat deployment yep like an
in the infantry oh and having your
friends blown up daily and you know
those guys are and women when they get
hurt did you talk to them when they get
hurt they feel guilty yeah that they
didn't die right now to get back with my
yet which is the most valiant and most
correct you're like what it's yeah you
made somewhat met a guy who you know um
his buddy dragged him out of a humvee
that got hit with an IED yeah and the
guys all one guys all kind of banged up
and then the other guy who dragged him
out of there won't leave aside and his
hands are bandaged and I like reached to
shake his hand and he just kind of holds
his band his hands up and I'm like oh
that's right you pull the guy out of a
burning fire right so you can't shake
hands right right right and you're just
like and you see that stuff you know we
fed shame and I fed kids through barbed
wire local kids who saw us coming and
this this soldier this woman
who's a really cool sergeant from the
Indiana National Guard was like hey I'll
show you guys and we bring bottled
waters and snacks and the kids see as
they run along the side of a minefield
and then you're feeding them yeah a
granola bar through razor wire and then
you come back and someone's mad you know
that their panini wasn't cooked
correctly yes and it's hard yes like
we're talking about this on comedy film
erds my podcast we did talked about
American sniper and just the whole you
know him coming back PTSD can adjust and
I was talking to a fan of our show this
guy Lucas lensman who was over there and
he was like that's the hardest part is
coming back like that scene in The Hurt
Locker yeah where he's looking his
wife's like pick out some cereal she's
like what and he's just staring at this
wall of cereal like I defuse bombs yeah
what this matters yeah I remember when I
came back from Afghanistan I drove to
Vegas to do a gig and I'll never forget
I was in the bathroom of a McDonald's I
stopped on the way and I heard these two
women complaining how filthy the bat oh
my god let's bathroom stealthy I can you
believe it and I remember being like
[__] you [__] you and your mother that
you're even complaining about this and I
remember coming back and having the
sense of I don't give a [__] like what
what am I caring about like credit card
debt or I'm giving a [__] about a
television show and what are we talking
about and you ever you get really really
clear really quick when you see war
really up close life gets real [__]
focused yeah yeah it's like if I came
back and sort of had to I mean I was
making them adjust our comics we're not
even soldered wasn't that weird talk I
know can you imagine you imagine can you
imagine we didn't see one of our friends
get blown away like the other comic
didn't take one in the in the net face
friends frenos friends for years you
went to boot can't you know like some
intense experience together and oh I was
at their wedding and now they're dead or
whatever and so I were bad so I came
back and was like you know I was just
hosting game
which was and then the whole and the
game shows went away and everything was
being replaced by reality TV and I
remember my host agent was a really good
guy goes Graham you know I got you ever
he goes I got to this audition at E I
said great cool could you know you got
to pay your bills of course but then he
said but I gotta be honest it was hard
to get you in there and I go why this
cuz it the woman at he goes we love
Grammys funny but I always feel like he
doesn't care and I was like oh don't I
don't give a [__] about e at all not in
the least they want to pay me i'll do it
i'll be i'll just be funny on camera
he's like it goes Graham come on I go
look at his name's John I go John here
the best name ever name's John paradise
I go you know you sound like a 60s TV
detective right that's your agents name
that was Isaiah had a guy named Steve
Stevens he was never happy Steve Stevens
in the mornings Stevie's on the ones and
two is steve stevens & duck face was his
coke yeah yeah no but his dad was Steve
Stephen senior he was a junior they were
worth a [__] show business oh so he's
telling you so your agents like you got
to get serious gotta get seriously I
culture as I go okay John look I go John
I won't make you look bad I'll go do a
good job I'll go in there sure and you
know the next time I'm in Iraq shaking a
wounded soldiers hand I'll try to keep
up with the kardashians he just laughs
it goes Graham I was like John don't
worry I'm not gonna [__] i'm not
going to [__] the bed on this but that
was sort of my attitude was like and I
was trying to get this documentary about
my first time over there getting made
called laughs ganna Stan and that was
taking like years to get made because we
didn't have any money and so I was
living at the beach and was just it was
hard to give a [__] about anything and
then a buddy of mine that I known for
years he went back to college in his 30s
[__] that's my dream man and what a
great idea and y'all should and he would
like either finished his first year with
maybe was even graduating or something
and he goes because look I present to
myself is I want to take surf lessons
let's do them together I set him in nice
and that was a labor day no excuse me
memorial day weekend
2006 so a month after the helicopter
shootout and everything and um I just
was like I literally I mean no pun
intended i immerse myself in surfing
because the ocean I mean they've done
studies like there's I'm quoting a bunch
of science I don't remember correctly so
what is that like an idiot but there's a
certain like the positive ions and
saltwater help you know whatever it
balances you out like there's a there's
a chemical reaction biological reaction
that I hands in salt water I believe it
and the stress release and I just was
like I fell in love with it and he and I
just forced ourselves were like we get
in the water three four five days a week
splash around get our asses kicked for
like 20 25 minutes and just crawl along
you know and by the end of the summer I
got a better board and by the end of the
summer I was standing up and surfing and
I was like this is and I member by the
end of the summer we were sitting me him
in this other friend of ours the this
guy jason ward we were just sitting on
the beach after a session I just went I
get it and I go what guys that just
check out yeah guys just go surfboard
backpack yep out I totally get it you
know and that's still my fantasy of just
like later show business like I'm gonna
live on a beach somewhere me too let's
go you know let's go to Tahiti that's my
that's my own have you been no but I
want to go to Tahiti I've been down to
Brazil I could do brasil I could do
anywhere Southeast Asia take my husband
though do you mind oh dude I know well
can't tell you cuz i took surf lessons
at 28 years old too cuz i was going
through a breakup and it's so funny how
people are led to surfing through some
kind of tragedy and cuz it's something I
always wanted to do I boogie boarded
like a nerd I grew up in the ocean I
adore the ocean and it's really hard
it's the most difficult thing because no
joy waves are the same the size and the
speed and the shock wave is different
well not only that just I'm talking the
physicality like let's say you want you
go all right I'm gonna serve today so
you got to get your ass up at what time
what time you wake up to surf I used to
be that like dawn patrol guy but now
do you know I gotta get the perfect wave
at the tide and all the stuff I'll still
kind of do that if there's a big
swelling but to me it's more just about
getting in the ocean so like in the
winner now in the waters colder I'll
wait till it's warmer and like if the
tides right during the middle of the day
I'll go during the middle of the day I'm
not getting up at 6am unless it's like
my god sweet but I see them down here
i'm not there at six in the morning but
i know that those bros have been there
all day but so you get up you got your
board which at least the board I learned
on a big-ass banana board that thing
weighs a ton for somebody like me you
got a pedal you gotta take it out into
the water you got to fight the currents
here because you don't know how to
[__] get on board and just paddle it
out there now I'm out there now you got
to turn your ass around and then you're
kind of bobbing and waiting for the wave
to come and then it comes and you gotta
paddle battle and then just getting up
on the board holy [__] yeah you got to
go quick that's easy to pop up yeah they
go pop up so you're going from laying
flat on your belly so now you're on your
two legs I see you like that's a spring
up like a push-up like a goal like a
Marine Corps style like try it now lay
on your belly those of you listening and
they're like just pop up I don't like
just about what and pop up and then
rotate your hips so you're now facing to
your right or left as opposed to
straight forward right and I'm goofy
footed or what I don't think I can
remember and I just it's so incredibly
hard but exhausting and exhilarating in
a great way because at the end of that
day of even just learning how to surf I
was your beat you're wiped and it's the
most hungry you're ever in your entire
life yeah yeah the combination of you
can't eat a lot before you get in yeah
and then spending whatever an hour to in
the water working every single muscle
muscle you don't even know you had and
then em it's [__] cold like in
California a lot of people don't know
this but our oceans not warm I'm sorry
even in the summertime for me that's
cold cuz I'm a chicken you know the
Atlanta I like the Atlantic like Florida
ocean nice and warm like bath water but
this is so how cold is the water today
let's say it's probably 60 degrees 58 to
62 practically ice and in the
summer that most it'll get is maybe 70
yeah so it's not it's not and you have
to wear the suit yeah you pee in the
suit you have to pee in it right I try
not to know they tell you to yeah we're
not god I hate admitting feel like an
animal but it's your pedes fine ass name
you can drink your pee it's sterile as
two separate first and wear it as a hat
to you don't wear your own urine I can
drink your own urine you can paint with
it these are great tips cooking tips
clean your laundry with it there's a lot
of stuff I mean what can't you do with
this guy's by this on my website now so
now here's the philosophy I know you
guys are thinking how are you possibly
gonna find something listen I'm not
saying there's some Western philosopher
that has written on that maybe there is
you know I just I didn't I didn't find
it if you guys know of anybody that has
a philosophy of surfing please send it
to me there's this wonderful article I
found in the utne reader it me right
that's how you say utne maddening but
you got to say this is a old old article
August July yeah august two thousand six
this is when you started surfing right
yeah we haven't surfing three months at
that point well this guy wrote this for
you ok so oh I forgot what Oh real quick
after I got back from my first
Afghanistan tour in 2004 the movie
riding giants had come out which is a
documentary about big wave surfing Laird
Hamilton it deals a history of it I know
his wife oh really did a pilot together
oh my god yeah what's her name
volleyball player yeah yeah she an
amazing gap Gabrielle Reece yeah
gorgeous and so nice so normal and I
came back from my first Afghanistan
tripping you know freaked out for those
reasons we talked about and my buddy
goes go see riding giants and go watch
it live or like see it in the theater
don't rent it watch on the big screen
and I was like oh you and that gets into
the philosophy and the soul of it and
you were like bro I'm in can I tell you
I saw this documentary all this mayhem
about the Pappas brothers of
skateboarders and I met when I watched
people skateboard and do that halfpipe
stuff that vert thing I'm like all if I
i want that i should i wish i could
that I wish in the 80s they encourage
little girls won't do that because I
would have right I love it just there's
something in that energy and what is
that energy so this is this fantastic
article this guy says I remember
listening to a Dharma talk five years
ago Oh a Dharma talk I thought it wise
name was Dharma I her let Johnny Sharma
that's your other agencies namaste we're
hanging it Steve come a Geneva nothing
Johnny Dharma I remember listening to a
Dharma talk five years ago by one of my
favorite teachers Jean Amaro a witty
British monk in the Thai forest
tradition who lives in a humble Hut the
mendocino forest in northern california
he used a surfing metaphor to explain
samsara the endless cycle of birth and
death which we know from Buddhism right
you're in you're in the the wheel of
[__] that's some song that's all the
book I think that's how I say it really
offices the wheel of [__] ladies and
gentleman this is my Buddhist game show
let's spin the wheel of [__] you're
in it the veils dropped you want stuff
you get stuff stuff doesn't make you
happy you have the stuff you're happy
for a little bit and then the stuff goes
away the grand prize is enlightenment
that's right Johnny exactly Johnny
Dharma exact they won and urban okay so
i used the serving men aboard explain
samsara and the eye the eye jean laughed
as he talked about the ridiculousness of
surfers this is funny they struggle to
paddle through the crashing surf in
search of their perfect wave but when
they finally catch when they get a
fleeting rush of adrenaline get shoved
under water come up breathless and then
struggle to get back out again for
another round this he said is dukkha i
don't know how to say it dhaka do cadena
holidays I know that I've ensue the
worst suffering he says this is the
essence of all suffering this is the
essence of what we're trying to get away
from this he said is dukkha suffering do
guys do come no no I said the word
before on this Sean I know if I'm sorry
but in essence it's it's lunacy he says
that we are addicted to the emotional
patterns that continually pound us down
we chase after them for a fleeting rush
but that rush is never quite enough but
then he goes on to say as a Buddhist
surfer I would like to suggest another
lesson we can glean for the sport so
then he has his thing I believe surfing
can teach us to ride some saara enjoy it
like a wave while still seeing through
it's a loooser e nature so on one hand
this guy's saying it's insanity is surf
here you are you're like it here this
this momentary thrill and it's not it
doesn't last that long and then you're
thrust into the water and you can't
breathe in and then these crazy people
do it again but this other guys saying
it's not necessarily that it's that in
that chaos you can kind of see through
the eye of an right your kind of riding
the wave so to speak you're becoming one
with the experience of chaos i would say
tim for me that surfing from a
philosophical and/or spiritual
standpoint is really it is a complete
metaphor for life and it's not just like
this other guy clearly is not a surfer
nerd yeah splashing around like it's
horrifying you're playing in the ocean
dudes my sweet you know savez you know
Elissa's 40-foot waves it could kill you
if you're just like chest high waves
it's a lot of fun um so to me and a lot
of surfers will say this you know like I
haven't been in the water in about a
week or two half because I was on the
road last week and that's like too long
like I just need to get out of water and
so when a surfer says that what that
means is it's not just catching the epic
wave it's just it is the paddle out it
is sitting on your board and there's no
twitter out there there's no cell phone
there is just the ocean you can't even
really hear people on the shore you know
and there's birds there's dolphins
there's the wind there's the Sun and
it's just it is just magical and it can
when you like a thing I do like about
getting up early or at least surfing
first thing in the morning is then the
rest of my day it just kind of stays
with me the rest of my days just a
little more mellow yeah because I kind
of have that with me and I mean that's
life you know there's always going to be
another wave so there's no reason to
panic when you can't get this one or
fall off or whatever
life is up and down um and it is about
being i mean i know this i'm quoting
like every new age [__] poster with
let's do it indian dreamcatcher
instagram account live your dream
aggressive and it's rachel at the same
time um i like it is about staying in
the moment and enjoying it for what it
is you know because if you are just like
oh I gotta get the next way but that
wave wasn't good enough or whatever that
I'm missing out on the beauty and
splendor I've gone out in the ocean and
just had like forty-five minutes because
I had a busy day or whatever may be
caught one or two waves they were
knee-high and it was it was magical now
I can get in my head and stress about
stuff while I'm sitting on my board you
know and and leave the moment leave the
you know have might let my brain take me
somewhere else but when I come back to
the present than it is an amazing thing
and it is truly I mean I i firmly
believe with me coming back from that
second Afghanistan tour it was pretty
gnarly and I remember we you know I
think I got saved my life to in a
certain extent not to be too dramatic
but absolutely it really brought some
focus back not that I was going to come
back and and I don't know kill myself
for whatever but it was hard man I'd sit
and I'd sit in my apartment in the dark
yeah spend oh for sure because it's like
what the [__] is the point you know and
I remember we were surfing at San Onofre
State Park which is down your camp
pendleton and so that's a marine corps
base for those of you don't know so
there's always military helicopters
flying and you know this a military
helicopter sounds a lot different than a
traffic light it's very distinct and I
see them here over the beach and I'm
like BAM yeah okay I'm sure you can hear
that [__] for a while yeah for sure 60
seconds before anybody else hears it I
know like I do that all the time we'll
be on our boards and some was talking
and I'll just stop and turn and then 30
to 60 seconds later them thing you know
and I remember being on our board that
summer of 06 after that firefight with
Shaima
juster I just are crying yeah i just
heard military helicopters and just
started crying i aware and uh it was
surfing that kind of centered me and
then I'll i was like that sort of the
everything now my whole life kind of
revolves around it to a certain extent
you know like monastic should and it's
like you I've talked about this off you
know off air is why why it is important
to live at the beach yeah and you know
I'm gonna hustle I'm in show business
and I help run a festival and I got a
road career and I gotta do all those
things to hustle to pay the bills but
I'm not letting that dominate who I am
anymore you know like I'm working hard
so that I can make money while I'm
sitting on my surfboard that's my goal
you know income passive income that's my
goal I want to just sit on my surfboard
and money's coming in and so that's me I
mean I'm not that great of a surfer I'm
not gonna turn pro or anything obviously
I like maybe they say except guys in
their 40s from Chicago but um that's
when you can start that's really helping
those kids you're gonna go to Hawaii but
it it is um it has helped me in so many
ways and it's just one of those things
like it just has to be a part of my life
and I've even dated girls or just like I
don't why are you in the want and I'm
like you get it sorry man you don't get
it and I think um not that I'm this
fantastic sir for now I'm eating towards
buying a board and going back into the
water because I'm desperate i go to the
beach a lot we went to Africa a couple
few years ago my husband died in to
Durban and every day we went to the
beach and I remember being and I just I
love it I'm so drawn to the water and we
were living in silverlake at the time
and I said to my husband wouldn't be
great like that we if we live somewhere
where I could go to the beach every day
and he's like what we do we do we live
in LA they're like oh bro oh so cal
let's do yeah and I was like yeah what
would you call your husband bro this is
awesome but yeah well you can and when
we did and the point is though I really
don't like when people reduce things
like surfing or stand up or mountain
climbing or if you don't know what
you're into art or not I'm sorry that's
a bad example
these extreme sports and they reduce it
to the adrenaline rush of it like I
really hate when people are like Oh
stand up you love the rush of making
people out i'm like 'that's there's some
part yes there's also the very the
nature of what you're doing which is
getting lost in the doing just as you
said it's not about doing a ma'am you
may have served for 45 minutes as
opposed to what you wanted to do today
three hours but it's just the doing of
this practice and taking you out of time
because that's you look you know you be
very painted and you like that eat hours
go by hours and what is that same with
stand up you know sometimes you'll dread
at least I do some nights like there's
no way I can get through the next hour
of telling jokes and that's because I'm
so reluctant to just get in the moment
and just be present in the moment and
then have those moments I'm sure where
you know you've been doing this a long
time now so you walk off stage and
someone ago that was so hilarious when
you said that thing yeah I didn't
remember because it was just so
beautiful and pure yeah it was so in the
moment and you're so tuned into who you
are as a comic and as an artist and as a
person that you just go yeah bing bang
bang bang in the whole crowd [__] out
like you ever had someone come up we
rent that show two years ago remember
you were like salad for I don't know I
don't know what that means at all we've
been laughing about that for two [__]
years my hand and I've been laughing
about salad I kind of remember that yeah
but what is that so what is that when
you tap into I think it's what you just
said what is everything you just said
it's the magic of the moment it is the
magic of I mean specific to stand up now
we're tapping into our talent and
ability and it's that thing of like a
gifted athlete who just but it can
happen sorry mrs. it can happen to
people who are painting when you're
driving you go into like a boo-boo I
don't know if that's the same
necessarily thing but sorry not to know
but anything you recognize I just golf
is somebody's thing you're gonna have
those moments they went I just walked up
and I just hit the most perfect shot I
didn't think about it I didn't want my
grip and everything and it just went and
for us we're professionals so we that's
why we're professionals is we have those
moments like a professional athlete
because the professional
late let's use the Gulf example again a
professional golfer has those moments
you know 50 times a day when they're
golfing were actus will practice helps
the practice house and a natural gift
and an ability and and all these other
factors that come into it but I think
then you're tapping into that that
moment where and I call it what you will
maybe you're connecting to the universe
or your higher power or whatever you
want to call that and you're just kind
of funneling this is just I'm doing it
without even thinking because sometimes
if we think too much that gets in the
way that's the problem your mind the
consciousness can actually hinder it I
believe that the month the mind is the
most powerful thing we have and it's the
most it can it can wreak havoc it's like
fire yeah you're right exactly I keep
you warm it can cook for you and can
burn everything to the ground and kill
you think about a breath deep bro oh
[__] wait so you can't uncle we just
digitally know yeah my brand is explode
but yes so that's but that is the
essence of it it can be your greatest
asset or it can be a torturer yeah i
mean look i go to my shrink twice a week
now and uh oh there are some days where
i can see it i go how I my worst enemy
why am I saying this [__] to myself why
am I I wouldn't say these things to
another human being and yet I put you
know you you can't park for [__] you're
fat Oh your guide you looked here Oh who
said I would never say this to my
husband or to my dog it's funny somebody
said that to me a while ago I was
beating myself up and actually I'm in a
support group so they they said would
you talk to your best friend that way
right like no I'm the cheerleader when
my best friend come you know any of my
friends come at me they're like well why
don't you start being your best friend
to yourself and as cheesy as that sounds
yeah and I was like this sounds like
some after-school special you're the
best you're my favorite gram I love you
like hug myself in a mirror like oh you
know like Kitty lunchbox or something
like this is this is horrifying yeah but
then I started kind of doing it and I
started talking to myself the way I
would talk to one of my buddies yeah and
when I start and I'll do that like you
idiot you then
especially show business because we can
go all day this my friend that I started
with I mean I could list of all the
people are giant famous TV shows that I
did open mics with 15 20 years ago no
crazy yeah or i can go I'm still making
my living in one of the most difficult
professions on the face of the year of
course so and I just say you know
sometimes I gotta look in a mirror I'll
go man you're doing find it you're doing
it's okay okay that was a misstep great
let's learn from it let's move here and
I literally got to just be the happy the
pep talk for myself and that was hard
thing to learn but it's really been
amazing and helpful as being there for
myself and getting my own back and
that's how I have sort of helped tame
and overcome this wild tiger that is my
brain yeah you know it doesn't surfing
help that it sure comes those I call
them the howling demons ito edited
meditation is that um sir fangar yoga
being out nature yeah it's fun anything
you saying you answer for sure like has
I and I firmly believe this it has a a
biological thing yet happens you know a
physiological thing happens when you're
in nature that you can't get from a
movie or a video game or whatever not
that those are I mean those are fine
distractions I watch a lot of movies
obviously but yeah it's the nature thing
man that's why I go on my rooftop might
have a roof deck at my building I go up
there every morning that's how I start
my just talk about this so I i also look
at you with somebody that's kind of got
their [__] together that way like i need
to get I want to get where you're at
physically you know I'm working on the
emotional spiritual let's get my ass in
shape so Graham walk me through your day
how can i how can I deal with
programming well I'll tell you what I do
and then I'll tell you what I've learned
and how it can please anybody listening
um I get up this morning I got up about
six o'clock 6 615 oh whoa whoa back it
up what time do you go to bed last night
probably 1030 ish and how much wine did
you drink last night well uh I've been
sober for 13 years of okay so no alcohol
no
how much cheese did you eat last night
you eat cheese and crackers I had seven
Oreos okay okay um I was actually
watching justified last night on my DVR
so I get up I eat just this is gonna
sound ridiculous but I drink a little
kombucha that's great that's good for
your Browns so good yeah um had a
handful of peanuts just to put some
protein in my system where's the coffee
and then you make your double latte I
don't drink coffee I drink green tea see
so far I know that's what I lose
everyone in the first 60 seconds like
emerald like no way so um that I go on
my roof and I bring a couple of books to
read I meditate and read some books what
do you read cuz I weighed two in the
morning I read a deepak chopra book okay
i might be back Deepak baby creating a
fluent love it um and I've been reading
that probably for four years now Wow and
it's I'm just reading it over and over
and over and it's just sort of like I'm
gonna write that down Ariza gets me
solid and then uh I read another book
from my support groups and uh gonna do
it all and then I've been been studying
martial arts for maybe 10 11 years now
very much a hobby not a badass and three
or four years ago I started doing
samurai sword which is such a Zen thing
and it's so precise and so I do that am
I because I can't do am I can do my
apartment I do it from in the kneeling
positions but a lot of overhead cuts and
so you kind of need be careful yeah
don't you don't want a roof in that
situation so I go on my roof and I
practice that and it's very much a Zen
thing you know the word samurai means to
serve and um you know my instructor was
always talking about how to or obviously
not gonna use this and it's not
practical application like a regular
martial art like if someone attacks you
I gotta get a sword fight plus there's a
zombie apocalypse I'm ready [__] my
weapon don't bug and freeze up oh that's
actually a really good point good never
not impractical don't need to reload
you guys are looking for new magazines
I'm just cutting through justice or the
next Hobbit movie they all sword fight
right yes um so I work on that and the
Technic there's all these it's very
precise and then I just you know I can
see the whole excuse me though ocean and
the whole city of Los Angeles and I just
that's how I start my day then I come
downstairs and then I turn my phone on
and start I don't I I'll tell you this
and I don't I'm not perfect but
sometimes I'll turn on my turn my phone
off when I sleep that's huge man people
like whatever some of theirs emergency
911 [__] we want me to do I'll
someone else yeah how's that for I'm not
a trained professional yeah um so then I
turned my phone on that I make breakfast
and then I get into my day no man it may
bring this point it's your regime is not
it's not totally dissimilar now I start
my night a little you know I stay up
late I drink wine and I e cheese and
then I wake up around nine thirty dead I
read I have my coffee I get jacked and I
read marianne williamson I like her I
read some meditation i like this guy
swami satchidananda i read him i get my
mind right and then i go into technology
meditation first get your [__] straight
get your mind right before you even
think about communicating with other
human beings when i turn my phone on
first and start communicating I know
even if I then go on my roof it's still
just a little I'm already like me
anybody know what I mean I'm too little
to wound and it just you're not you're
not gonna come across cool you know like
you're not gonna you're not going to
send a good cogent thing right if its
first thing in the morning and you're
maybe you're an agitated right you want
to be kind of calm before you approach
the world yeah and some of it you know
especially if you get any sort of email
that's like what we need the blah blah
blah and it's sometimes what I after if
I do my roof the right way then I can go
okay well hold on I don't have to
respond to this immediately let me out
let me ask this person you know like get
that get the fat get to sit down compose
the email whatever mm-hmm and then I can
just kind of like okay right out what
I'm going to do for my day and then
and then that's how and then I rode my
bike to yoga so that you do yoga so this
morning we've done swords already super
where you've already done like something
good and then you're gonna go yoga for
extra points I ride my bike to yogis by
1520 my bike rider yoga geez that's at
nine o'clock that goes till about ten
forty-five my god and I read my back
bike back home along the beach and I see
the ocean I think this stuff is so like
your surroundings and you know this from
the road yeah you get into some town or
in some dodgy hotel room or whatever and
who your around your physical
surroundings the people you're around
you know I've had to sort of weed out
some people in my life because they were
too negative and you know what I can get
really negative I can be a judgmental
dick and that's bad for me so I'm like
around people that are positive and
funny and talented and and you know I've
heard a great slogan which is take what
you want leave the rest and I start
applying that to everything and I'm a
lot happier and you know cuz it was I
went to a tough thing man I went through
you know I had some real tough financial
trouble because I put all this time and
effort into making a documentary about a
war that nobody cares about and um uh
did we care I care well thank you you're
beautiful and I should say that some of
the people have seen my movie like it
and families of military people have
liked it and stuff like that but it you
know it cost me a lot of money is it out
now can people watch it help you know to
Afghanistan if you go to comedy filmers
dot-com you can download it it's a pay
what you think is fair download so you
can get it for a buck okay or whatever
it'll be on my website too so you guys
can check it out but like and then I
sort of rejected show business and then
didn't have an agent her manager wasn't
really doing it other than trying to get
this movie made and then had a lot of
financial trouble and then the recession
hit and you know I had this house that I
had bought and lost it and went through
all that financial stuff and then went
through a divorce and it was [__]
hard crayons a lot and it was like I it
was one of the reasons why I had
do like do this regimen because it was
like the demons are right [__] there
waiting to take me down like its wits it
was hard for the first time in my life I
had a confidence problem which I've
never really had and it was just like
you know maybe I suck maybe I'm not good
maybe I shouldn't be in show business
maybe that's why I'm failing and all my
friends are getting TV shows and movies
and blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
and so it's wide surfing was sort of the
gateway I mean I'd always been healthy
I've been a vegetarian since 2000 I've
always worked out in some degree or
another um but I really had to do I
realized how out of shape I was
spiritually like I was you know and it's
why I just you know I stopped drinking
and all this stuff and it was like
that's the other thing when I stopped
drinking in 2002 I had to start facing
myself I want that and it was obviously
want that it's every night you don't you
don't drink ever how about alone don't
face yourself once a week Riley what
about by yourself are you supposed to
drink alone right with the lights off
and a katana yeah that's what they tell
it isn't that's on the side of the
bottle don't they tell you to do okay
just making sure dinner so yeah man it's
why I have to be really strict with
della go fit vigilant vigilant word and
here's the thing man you know I got my
demons to vie childhood scurry listen my
mother was a nut bag I was my mother's
mentally ill no one got into comedy
because everything was great nobody yeah
nobody was a decent sense of humor yeah
yeah you know I grew up a lot so I I
have those childhood things and I
overall i will say i'm a pretty happy
person I'm lie I'm I like my life you
come across very sad today you across
very positive to me and even though like
the first time I hadn't seen you in a
while and we did the ice house
chronicles together oh my god they just
laughed it was like six or seven
automakers last year we just laugh and
we talked about how great the beach was
and then we've sort of reconnected on
hey let's see do each other's podcast
but when I came in here to I've never
been to your house I came in and you
were like hey and your vibe and your
energy definitely said all these things
well cuz cuz I thank you I appreciate
that because i don't i believe in what
you were saying is that listen we're all
human beings and human beings have two
sides the force what's Star Wars about
what's the [__] Hobbit about what's
harry potter about it's all about the
same thing you can choose darkness or
you can strive for the light and it's
harder to go to the path of the
righteous yes the light because darkness
is Oliver and it's here's a scary thing
it's not all around it can be around you
and it can feed most definitely the
comedy club environment can be dark the
employees can be dark the hotel room can
be dark unfortunately your own mind is
the origin of a lot of darkness too and
even if you haven't had severe trauma or
a divorce the most human beings have a
tape running in their heads that is not
cool yeah and it's either do I listen to
this tape or do I use what what I can to
transcend this [__] and I think it
gets louder for us because we have all
this down time on the road know that
yeah you mean the 23 hours are not
working yeah in a hotel room and with
the dead of winter hmm and it's like
okay I guess I'll put my shoes on and go
to the CVS because I need toothpaste
when you and that's your big event that
dad's the event that day and then
finally at your polite like no chipotle
on the road good healthy and you get
your group silk and righteous yeah under
10 bucks yeah yeah I'd road meal
Chipotle's look at heaven yeah well it's
so sad but still small things that make
you happy anyways here's some
interesting article I read on this is
another thing where I got this from of
spirituality health com some article and
then surfing okay okay so does this
sound familiar to you for those of us
who don't surf what's it like when
you're riding a wave you're physically
writing energy the memory of wind energy
that's pulsing between water molecules
you really do become part of
the wave especially in the hollow I'm
assuming that's the whole the tunnel
right you're really inside of that
vortex of spiraling energy well liked it
you'll hear surfers who have no
background in the metaphysical or Zen
say I rode that wave and didn't feel
like I existed the wave was there i was
there we were together when a feeling of
merging with an energy that is much
greater than yourself which i think you
said at the beginning of the show right
like your molecular lee connected i
agree i feel that you riding mode riding
the energy of the earth yeah yes BAM and
when you fight it you get your ass
kicked BAM you I know will you ever been
in the ocean and you ever get [__] in
a wave like and not even surfing just I
love to swim and I love to feel the
motion and it yes more resist like let's
say their current comes or you get
smushed by a wave don't fight it I
remember you just kind of chill hang out
man hang out push yourself up when you
can never turn your back on it number
one don't turn your back on that [__]
she will take you down to chinatown
right never turn your back on the ocean
yeah that's the thing as an another sort
of life lesson is yeah you try to fight
it try to control something you can't
control you will go you'll get your ass
kicked you'll get crazy you get hydrated
you know that's it that's the whole
point of surfing and writing riding the
wave why that's what people say that
because you can fight the current of
life where you can kind of you can hire
this on over one time she said you can
if you're rowing in a canoe you can just
let go of the oars and let the current
take you yeah yes and no you know you
should have an idea of where you want to
go but sometimes when you're in it
you're just like in shaw insha Allah as
they say right in the Eastern world well
what the [__] am I get it's up to God
yeah it's in God's hands a lot of the
stuffs in God's hands most of it except
you and you're good let me ask you this
question though remember that girl in
Australia who went into the ocean and
then the shark bitter arm off that movie
Soul Surfer
Hawaii sorry everything place it's all
dangling good day mate whatever cares
doesn't matter place um so she she'd
this poor girl surfing she gets her arm
eaten by a shark and then she's like I'm
gonna go do it again and she's still
serves today hmm I gotta tell you I
don't agree with that at all and I mean
that like if something takes my arm I'm
bill you know what maybe I'm not meant
to maybe I'm gonna try when i try
boogie-boarding that do the due boogie
boarders get eaten as much as surfers I
don't know like I I've never seen i I've
seen some like four foot leopard sharks
you know they're here yeah get your life
really yeah hey I was just like oh I
know you know the behavior of those
sharks they're just like they're they'd
like shallow water they're not gonna
come at me unless I step on once i just
moved away from him but if I saw like a
seven to ten foot like great white or
tiger shark or something like that I
don't I might lose my [__] let alone if
someone bit me I don't know if I'd get
back in the water but it's hard to say
maybe I would I don't need [__] your
arm off my arm all I know I know I don't
know yeah I don't know what I would do
yeah like really is it is it really a
triumph of the soul to be like I'm gonna
go back into the same thing that almost
killed me I'm not sure I agree with that
but we're supposed to value that is
that's a virtue like she's dumb enough
to go back in that water no dude pick
something else up it since it would be
it's suicide at that point right I'm
sorry Mike horrible am I totally off
here I know I'm supposed to be inspired
by that movie just angered me that you
get back in this earth day the bunk on
the beach what are you doing what do you
do it yeah I don't ya I think your point
of view is hilarious ok I love comics
because they will come up with something
I hadn't thought of even if I don't
agree with it I'll go that's funny it's
funny but am I wrong I'm being seriously
I don't think it's a lot right or wrong
conquering that fear or something well
again I don't know what I would do if I
ever that ever happened I've been in the
water when I know there's
maybe you know what one time I buddy
mine was it a break and a great white
breached like 15 20 30 feet out there
but I mean I know the behavior of sharks
they mostly don't want to attack you
they don't want to bite humans but it
could happen statistically it's like I
get a better shot at winning this 317
million dollar Powerball that's playing
yeah so to me that story was
inspirational cuz I was like well I
don't know if I could but she did it she
went back in you know go for it well
[__] her what did you but I also see
your point of view I left so I'm like
[__] I told you don't go in there
everybody told you to stop surfing
nobody wants you to do it again yeah why
are you doing this I never yeah I get
back on the horse why all right horses
are stupid buying horses so how much do
you hate horses they are the worst I do
haters it's [__] horse Wow time all
right well um Graham any other thoughts
is there anything we've missed that
maybe you'd like to say why'd you say
this you know when you were asking me
about like my regimen every day um
here's what I'll say just for you or
anybody else when it comes to like
exercise oh yeah Ellie please find the
thing that works for you like uh Jim am
I don't go to the gym anymore I had a
hip thing I could I swim laps hmm i surf
I ride my bike and I do yoga okay like I
like bikes and yoga that's what I'm
saying like fun whatever it is if it's
if it's Jazzercise if it's pole dancing
if it's hitting a heavy bag whatever
that thing is and however you can make
it work in your life like before I had
this hip injury I would do those
insanity workouts in my hotel room cuz I
just you know I got boy energy so I like
jumping around and let's do it you know
and then and then my hip was starting to
mess with me so I couldn't do that
anymore so now I swim laps I always stay
in a hotel with a pool or something
that's a good idea and I do yoga in my
room and like swimming laps 30 minutes
head to toe work out lean and then the
and then the
the changing what I was eating like
diets like crazy diets don't work or all
I'm gonna do without and punish myself
no no it just start substituting things
but you know do some research and like I
read the book eat right for your blood
type that helped me and I've recently
been reading some stuff about all of the
natural sugars that are in a lot of
foods and you know the American diet oh
my god it's guys can't imagine it's a
it's a garbage heap because when I go on
the road and I'm in the hotel and I
asked the guy or the lady at the front
desk hey what's good to eat around here
yeah steak and shake yeah but we got a
burger burger I go is all America only
eats cheese burgers and hotdogs and any
dog [__] yeah why you guys eating I mean
nobody eats a vegetable hey do you know
what one is ya seen one it kills me it
really it really breaks my spirit but
sorry but go ahead yes so that's the
thing like and fine and I really had to
make it work for me on the row cuz the
road is hard little crush your spirit
but when i start to when i eat healthy
on the road and when i'm working out I
feel better and it's kept me in good
shape you look amazing well thank you
guys look up grandma what's your
Instagram at grandma what is my
Instagram and it's g ra h am elw oh oh
gee look at grandma look at this man he
looks better than anybody else in LA and
he doesn't like plant he doesn't have
like even how like facial words no
you're you're how old are you 72 I'm 72
years old look amazing just had eyelash
implants yeah they're really helpful and
I'm single oh no are you single let
those ladies yeah so look I'm gonna be
doing your podcast comedy film nerds
podcast find him at Graham Elwood on
Twitter Graham Elwood calm and look up
his movie laughs ganna Stan also have
you seen that movie restrepo restrepo is
like that movie was so intense and I'm
sure yeah I saw that and when I wish I
could have done a show up there yeah me
too right bad for him I know so many
comics who were like I would have flown
up there and done a show easy I would
drop me there I would do it yeah I know
it's so crazy to do I just tell you one
time
so I did a show and they all just came
back from patrolling these Marines like
just fresh in off and they had their
rucksacks and everything and they were
just sitting on their rucksacks and
you're in this like weird it's always
like a dining hall or like some
makeshift yeah push the couches to the
wall Marines will build you a stage out
of matchsticks in 10 minutes you can
break it all down you're like how the
hell did you guys have a rain shower in
my tent they're amazing but uh yeah I'll
never forget that because I remember
seeing what world they were in versus
the world I inhabited at that and I
could see it for the minute I delivered
my first job like oh these these guys
had just seen some [__] like they had
just come in from something I am I can't
even comprehend it was a slow process of
us connecting you know you do that with
an your office there's there those blank
stares yeah yes and it's not that they
don't like you don't find out about me
and [__] I remember just again I I
did a similar thing these guys had just
come off patrolling this like 23 year
old kid his face is all dirty and he's
leaning against yeah and he was just
looking around like what there's some
guy in a Cubs Jersey telling jokes
that's the weirdest thing for them I'm
at home and then they thank you in ways
that you can't even put into words yeah
it's pretty [__] gnarly man so gnarly
huh well anyways do you know what that
is what's it let's deep bro ah thanks
for being here Graham thank you yeah
awesome all right listen I'm gonna play
a song now know what philosophize
wedding supplies with
yeah it's christina p aka miss Jean's
this ain't your mom's house it's a
different theme gotta be critically
thinking about a cocktail party on dogs
start thinking John Locke or what's a
Cypress East Aristotle Plato maybe
Hippocrates got us talking all properly
topically just the comedian discussing
these philosophies serious questions
silly people what's that nasty
it is the ultimate metaphor for life and
you know what that is but as deep brown
is deep bro bro